une vidéo toute simple publiée tard
mardi sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est ainsi que les patineurs tessa
virtue et scott moir yeux ont annoncé
leur retraite du patinage à la voix
empreinte d'émotion scop beaulieu a
remercié le public et expliquer qu'il
s'agit du bon moment pour se retirer
alors que tessa et lui aime encore leur
sport comme ils l'ont toujours fait
la patineuse de 30 ans a tenu à
remercier les amateurs pour leur soutien
indéfectible
tous deux natifs de london en ontario
virtue et moir ont remporté leur premier
titre olympique en sol canadien à
vancouver en 2010 après deux médailles
d'argent à sotchi
ils avaient annoncé leur retraite une
première fois mais la soif de vaincre
les avait rappelé à la compétition en
2016 deux ans avant le rendez-vous de
pyongyang
c'est là qu'ils ont connu l'apogée de
leur carrière avec le titre par équipes
et une médaille d'or en danse gagné in
extremis devant le couple français
papadakis cizeron les deux patineurs ont
fait leur marque grâce à leur chimie
inégalée sur la glace leur partenariat
aura duré 22 ans tessa et scott
salueront leur public canadien une
dernière fois lors d'une tournée le
spectacle avec des passages prévus à
laval et à québec les 14 et 15 novembre
les patineurs se retire avec de nombreux
titres et records
mais ce qui aura touché le coeur des
amateurs plus que leur victoire
c'est la magie qui prend forme chaque
fois qu'ils s'élancent côte à côte sur
la glace et si jacinthe haillan radio
canada montréal
[Musique]